[Musique]
eux ils se sont installés là il ya
plusieurs générations je pense qu'ils
disent pas de bêtises je m'en souvienne
mais c'est à peu près les arrière grands
pères des anciens qui sont là en ce
moment qu'ils ont découvert en fait que
le baobab pouvait être un contenant donc
dos en mourir j'aurais dû signer sur le
web c'est extraordinaire cette présence
qui peuvent avoir
après c'est vrai que dans le milieu
naturel c'est autre chose qu'en ville
par exemple j'ai vécu à mahajanga
pendant longtemps il ya des baobabs
partout en ville
mais c'est différent là ils sont
vraiment dans leur milieu naturel
on a l'impression en fait de croiser des
du vivant c'est comme j'imagine que ça
doit être un petit peu la même ambiance
de quand on va voir les bouddhas géants
en asie
le projet c'est une rencontre donc avec
cyril cornu qui est spécialiste des
baobabs de madagascar j'ai toujours
admiré ces photos qui sont assez
extraordinaire et son film qui est
vraiment magnifique ans plonge
complètement à la beauté du monde et un
jour on s'est dit il faudrait qu'on
fasse quelque chose ensemble
on est à une phase de notre évolution où
on doit se poser et on se pose des
questions
ou est ce qu'on s'est trompé et j'avoue
que je me rassure parce que je me dis
y'a moyen de s'en sortir avec rien et
une prouve
tous les jours dimanche peut-être qu'on
le refrain si ça a du succès dimanche je
vais je vais guider les joints dans
l'expo en fait pour leur expliquer un
petit peu le projet le travail que j'ai
fait après le projet et puis raconter un
petit peu toute cette aventure c'est
vraiment une façon de pouvoir voyager à
peu de frais en ce moment on n'a pas la
possibilité de bouger et c'est une
évasion je pense après il faut
s'intéresser et puis il y avoir échangé
[Musique]